what is up with the living in your mom's
basement you're obviously making great
money is it so comforting to you to be
with your mom I was looking at plate I
lived on my own from 17 to 25 and then I
moved back home when things got a little
hectic and then right when right before
the pandemic it I was getting ready to
move into my own place again and then
the pandemic and I was just like you
know it's probably safest if I was with
my family so I'm just under staying here
riding it out with them how are you
occupying yourself in the basement all
day you know I always forget you're like
26 years old you must masturbate like a
maniac yeah I try to get a two-timer in
every day I try to try to get a morning
and afternoon and or maybe at night one
fantastic yeah there's just so much time
to fill when you live with your mom do
you live in fear of her catching you
masturbating like has she ever caught
you every day I make sure she's either
showering or cooking something or I I
need at least a minute and a half buffer
to make sure that I don't get caught it
is definitely it's my biggest fear right
now we're all just kids trying to not
get caught masturbating by our moms the
best part of the movie is when your mom
starts dating of course did your mom or
your life start dating and did you freak
out no well she never did date that's
one of the reasons I wanted to make the
movies because like I wanted to show her
that it was okay for like we would be
okay if she started dating I think she
should be getting laid constantly after
putting up with me and my sister her
whole life right why did you mom and
every date was it like oh my husband was
so great I could never be with another
man or was it like she felt guilty
around you kids like she didn't want you
to see that what what was going on there
I think it was a mix of both and I think
you know I was such a troublesome kid I
don't think she really felt like she had
the time to do so so I feel like I kind
of took that away from her so my hope
now is that she starts dating and gets
out there and really lives for herself
because you know she just put so much
into me and my sister
you
you